bonsoir maintenant 7 8 le journal tout
de suite les titres de ce lundi 15
décembre le commissariat de trappes
fermés ce samedi soir en pause un dégât
des eaux importants survenus dans la
journée le syndicat alliance dénonce des
manques de moyens renforcement des
fréquences de train entre la verrière et
la défense notamment le dimanche
les usagers sont satisfaits presque si
vous avez déménagé que vous souhaitez
voter dans votre nouvelle commune pour
les prochaines élections départementales
et régionales ne tardez pas les
inscriptions sur les listes électorales
seront closes au 31 décembre il sera
aussi question ce soir de la journée
universelle de l'espéranto avec notre
invité anne sophie markov ce sera dans
quelques instants
dans ce journal nous parlerons également
politique avec les départementales sport
avec la soufflerie tant attendu par
l'équipe de france de cyclisme ou encore
à des fêtes de ville à la verrière et à
magny les hameaux
je vous le disais dans les titres le
commissariat de trappes a été fermé
samedi soir
en cause un dégât des eaux depuis les
toits terrasses actuellement en travaux
un dégâts suffisamment important pour
entraîner donc la fermeture de
l'établissement et déplacer les
fonctionnaires de permanence et des
gardés à vue vers les commissariat de
guyancourt et d'elancourt c'est la
goutte d'eau on peut le dire pour le
syndicat alliance qui dénonce des
manques de moyens c'est un commissaire
acquis et classés en zones de sécurité
prioritaire donc il aurait dû
normalement quand les zones de sécurité
prioritaires ont été créés il devait y
avoir des moyens conséquents à louer ces
zones de sécurité prioritaires ont été
créés en tout cas sur trappe avec peu de
moyens supplémentaires
ces travaux auraient dû être engagé
immédiatement
il faut attendre
que les organisations syndicales en tous
cas alliance police nationale dénonce
cette inondation parce que nous ne
sommes pas au premier dégât des eaux des
autorités se sont déplacés ce matin pour
constater les dégâts
pour le commissaire trappe nous
demandons enfin un budget conséquent
pour même si effectivement des travaux
sont en cours
nous demandons à ce que le comice à ce
que ce genre de faits ne se reproduisent
plus on a épuisé h et que le
commissariat accueil de trappes
accueille à nouveau le public et les
travaux se poursuivent élections
maintenant les départements tasser pour
le mois de mars pour ce prochain plus
précisément les 22 et 29 mars
il s'agira d'un délire donc ce qui
siègeront au conseil général
nouvelle législation oblige le nombre de
cantons a été réduit de 39 à 21
mais les conseillers généraux élus le
seront dorénavant en binôme paritaire
hommes femmes
alors après l'ump c'est au tour du parti
socialiste de présenter ses candidats
ce week-end le binôme en lice pour le
canton de maurepas a été présenté il n'y
aura pas d'union de la gauche au premier
tour et vainqueur en 2008 à la faveur
d'une triangulaire avec deux candidats
de droite
ismaël havane se présente pour un
nouveau mandat avec lui marie christine
mercier première adjointe de manier les
hameaux le découpage des cantons a été
revu le canton de maurepas comprend
dorénavant magny les hameaux coignières
ou encore voisins le bretonneux
un changement qui ne me préoccupe pas
les socialistes pas plus inquiète
d'ailleurs d'un éventuel vote sanction
moi je suis conseiller général sortant
c'est une campagne locale a priori le
cette élection doit se jouer sur des
problématiques locales et nous élus de
gauche nous avons un bilan
à défendre qui un bilan que je considère
être bon donc en ce sens je ne suis pas
inquiet parce que nous nous allons
porter notre campagne sur nos actions
sur l'action des élus de gauche sur mon
bilan à moi en tant que conseiller
général si cette campagne et comme elle
doit l'être sur l'action locale les gens
feront la part des choses est fini je
suis plutôt confiant sur cet aspect là
notre axe de campagne ça nous allons
axer sur la solidarité l'écouté le
dialogue
l'égalité des chances pour tous et aussi
l'accompagnement à la dépendance pour
les personnes âgées qui sont en
augmentation croissante et qui vont
l'être dans les 20 à 30 prochaines
années
reste que ce canton sera difficile à
emporter pour la gauche de parlerait de
redécoupage c'est l'ump yves vandewalle
issus du secteur de chevreuse qui se
retrouvera donc face aux socialistes ils
siègent au conseil général depuis 2001
verdict donc des urnes au mois de mars
et si vous voulez voter donc en mars
prochain et que vous venez de déménager
il vaudra il vous faudra vous inscrire
sur les listes électorales et vous
n'avez que jusqu'au 31 décembre pour le
faire après il sera trop tard
explications au sein de ce service état
civil en mairie de guyancourt
service état civil de la mairie de
guyancourt depuis le début de l'année le
service a enregistré 200 inscriptions
supplémentaires sur une liste électorale
la commune compte à ce jour 17 1870
inscrits et depuis quelques jours c'est
un peu plus l'affluence
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
se fait du 1er janvier au 31 décembre et
ont clos les listes électorales ou 31
décembre de l'année en cours est passé
cette date il n'est plus possible de
s'inscrire tous les nouveaux arrivants
dans les communes tous les gens qui ont
déménagé au sein de la même commune et
tous les gens qui arrivent enfin qui
déménage dans une autre commune doivent
absolument signaler leur changement
d'adressé sur place vous devez fournir
un justificatif de domicile et une pièce
d'identité
c'est une procédure que chacun peut
également faire sur internet la mairie
de guyancourt ouvre aussi une permanence
le mercredi 17 décembre à la maison de
quartier auguste renoir
les données sont ensuite entrés dans un
logiciel de traitement des listes
électorales les cartes d'électeurs
seront imprimés au mois de février pour
être transmise aux titulaires avant le
premier tour des élections
départementales prévues le 22 mars après
le 31 décembre il n'est donc plus
possible de s'inscrire sauf cas très
particulier il ya quelques cas
dérogatoires mais faut être militaire
éventuellement si on a six ont été mutés
puis qu'on revient en france on peut
s'inscrire mais c'est vraiment très très
peu de cas les naturaliser les
naturalisés français qui sont
naturalisés avant l'élection et ensuite
les jeunes qui auront 18 ans la veille
de l'élection
une commission de révision des listes
électorales composé des lecteurs
notamment est chargé de valider toutes
les inscriptions ainsi que les
radiations
cette commission se réunira le 10
janvier le 28 février et cinq jours
avant le début de l'élection
deux échéances électorales sont prévues
en 2015 les élections départementales
donc fin mars et les élections
régionales en décembre et de nouveaux
maintenant en matière de transports les
usagers de la ligne u entre la verrière
et la défense vont voir l'offre
renforcée notamment les dimanches
plus de trains entre la verrière et la
défense actuellement le dimanche et les
périodes de fêtes entre la verrière et
la défense il n'y a qu'un train par
heure
dorénavant à partir de 11 heures il y
aura un train toutes les demi-heures
comme sur les lignes c est n soit 19
trains supplémentaires par ailleurs en
semaine afin d'offrir une fréquence plus
régulières entre les lignes à c n ai eu
au départ de saint quentin en yvelines
soit une fréquence de 15 minutes
deux trains supplémentaires seront créés
au départ de la verrière à 15h35 et
23h50 ce lundi en gare de la verrière
les usagers étaient partagés sur ces
annonces
là ils ont changé les horaires
normalement c'était à 11h05 et
maintenant c'est à 11h20 mais c'est ça
aide pas de ne pas nous prévenir
il se sentait pas qu'il a plus d'être
ici se fit connaître
il respecte les horaires qu'il n'y a pas
de problème parce que c'est ça qui
bloque c'est qu'on ne sait jamais
combien de temps va passer attendre le
train et puis pour combien de temps et
lavera livre arrivera ça à sa
destination le fait de rajouter des
trains c'est intéressant pour ceux qui
travaillent depuis ce qu'on va dire que
c'est bien de qui est plus de
de plus d'horaires enfin quand même
le week end qu il ya beaucoup de gens
qui travaillent le week end voilà c'est
très très bien parce que lé moment quand
on a les trains qui s'en seront
supprimés c'est à plus de train c'est
vraiment formidable pour nos allées un
tout autre sujet matin pour continuer en
ce lundi 15 décembre c'est la journée
universelle de l'espéranto l'espéranto
est une langue qui a été conçu à la fin
du 19e siècle par un docteur polonais
louis lazare zamenhof dont le but était
de faciliter la communication entre
personnes de langues différentes
on peut dire que c'est une sorte de
langue universelle son fondateur a
d'ailleurs publié en 1887 un projet de
l'ong internationale sous le pseudonyme
de dr espéranto docteur qui espère c'est
une langue aujourd'hui parler est
pratiqué dans plus de 100 pays sur cinq
continents et pour en parler avec nous
ce soir
une française anne-sophie markov et vous
allez nous parler en français bonsoir
vous êtes espérantiste de naissance et
vous animer des ateliers à châteaufort
des ateliers donc d'espéranto et vous
êtes accompagné également de kim
bonsoir tua 11 ans et tu pratiques
l'espéranto depuis le mois de septembre
alors d'abord dit markov quelle est la
construction grammaticale de l'espéranto
et vient l'espéranto comprend 16 go 16
règles grammaticales qui sont sans
exception
c'est ce qui fait sa facilité mais en
essence déception c'est à dire que
lorsque vous apprenez les règles de
grammaire et bien une fois que vous
l'avez vous les avez apprise vous savez
qu'il faut les appliquer telle quelle
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'exception donc
vous n'avez pas par exemple la
conjugaison comprend 12 terminaison au
total lorsque vous avez appris les douze
terminaison de
de la conjugaison et bien vous savez
conjuguer tous les verbes c'est facile
douze français c'est facile à dire mais
elle pour arriver à pratiquer ça reste
une langue qu'il faut apprendre avec le
vocabulaire est et ce qui est difficile
comme dans toutes les langues
c'est d'appliquer les règles que l'on
apprend et toutes les lettres ces prêts
sont des lettres comme nos lettres à
nous elle se prononce tout elle seule
alors les lettres se prononce tout
toujours de la même façon quelques
lettres via pas d'accent cessa candidats
même façon s'il n'y a pas d'action il ya
des ce qu'on appelle des soupirs sig
nouilles c'est à dire des petits signes
sur certaines lettres ça ressemble à des
accents circonflexes par exemple mais en
fait ces accents font partie de la de la
lettre donc lorsqu'on apprend l'alphabet
espéranto on a à 28 lettre à prendre on
les apprend une bonne fois pour toutes
avec la prononciation
une fois qu'on a appris avec la juste
prononciation peut plus tromper il faut
pas faire enfin si on peut se tromper si
on est étourdi mais mais les règles
restent toujours les mêmes et vous dites
28 lettres s'avère qu'il ya des lettres
qu'il n'existe pas de notre alphabet
dans l'espéranto c'est à dire que par
exemple le est-ce que vous ce que l'on
sait écrire en français
il se prononce toujours so en espéranto
et si on met un petit chapeau dessus
c'est une autre lettre donc ça se
prononce chaud et est toujours de la
même façon
de la même façon vous avez le sait qui
s'écrit comme le sait français vous
mettez un petit chapeau et vous avez une
nouvelle lettre qui se prononce chaud
alors que ça alors là c'est
effectivement on voit marqué par lasser
le choisir le nom du fondateur de
l'espéranto
c'est sa signature ces assises est là
sur deux avions peur justement un petit
mot sur louis de lazare zamenhof
ils étaient polonais effectivement
racontez nous un peu son histoire qu'est
ce qui lui a donné l'envi comme ça
d'écrire et bien lorsqu'il les autres
j'ai envie de dire c'est surtout une
histoire de son village qui est
intéressant le 15 décembre c'est sa date
de naissance en fait c'est ce que nous
fêtons aujourd'hui il est né le comme
vous l'avez dit le canot à 120 on le
voit la jeune etc c'est le voilà comment
comment il était lorsque sa langue était
à peu près au point et quand il
s'entraînait avec avec ses camarades de
classe parce qu'il faut dire que son
visage qui est un village donne
aujourd'hui était un village où il y
avait énormément de mélange ethnique et
que du coup ça devrait donner leur lait
n'est à bialystok qui est aujourd'hui en
pologne mais qui se trouvait à l'époque
en dans l'empiré russe donc ça mais neuf
a constaté dans cette dans cette ville
que les gens vivent parler des langues
très différentes
et en parlant des langues différentes
les gens se faisait des erreurs il ne se
comprenaient pas il y avait des conflits
qui apparaissait à cause de ses erreurs
linguistique et donc il s'était hissé
promis de de défier le mythe de babel
c'est à dire de d'essayer de vaincre
cette punition imposée par part dieu qui
sait qui s'est vu
concurrencé par par les hommes à une
époque wild où ils s'entendaient trop
bien je sais pas s'il a vaincu le mythe
de babel mais aujourd'hui combien
d'espérantistes au monde
alors voilà la question difficile à
laquelle tout le monde aimerait y
répondre avoir une réponse juste
nous aimerions être plus nombreux que
nous ne le sommes mais nous sommes déjà
plus nombreux que vous ne le pensez
probablement pâti je ne me risquerai pas
ordinaire de chiffre qui serait
forcément puisque le seul moyen de
calculer les espérantistes c'est de
compter ceux qui sont dans les
associations
ceux qui sont adhérents officielle des
associations or l'espéranto est une
langue donc
un drapeau je coupe alors dès le drapeau
drapeau voilà c'est le drapeau
espérantiste l'étoile verte a été choisi
par agm enough l'époque du premier
congrès espérantiste en 1905
et c'est devenu le symbole de de
l'espéranto
alors je dis vous animer des ateliers
chateaufort d'espéranto et parmi vous
êtes vous avez une vingtaine d'élèves à
peu près nous sommes nous à tête dans
l'association est parmi vous élève hakim
qui me tient aux ans explique moi
pourquoi tu as choisi de faire de
l'espéranto c'est étonnant parce que les
autres lendemain ses propres à chaque
pays
alors que l'espéranto c'est une langue
qui enfin c'est comme enfin en anglais
c'est c'est bien mais j'étais plus
proche des landes un peu latine fin qui
était plus fin plus proche de
l'espéranto que de l'anglais c'est un
peu la teinte cessant l'espéranto en
fait quand on quand on commence à
apprendre l'espéranto on reconnaît les
langues qu'on connaît déjà
c'est à dire que selon vos connaissances
personnelles vous allez reconnaître des
choses différentes par exemple c'est
vous bonsoir en espéranto ça se dit
comment on l'espère d'accord
oui ça me sens un peu latin oui parce
que l'accent tonique tombe sur l'avant
dernière syllabe de manière systématique
et donc
effectivement elle et c'est une langue
qui est assez chantante
c est ce que tu trouves ça facile là
c'est plus facile que certaines langues
qu'on apprend à l'école comme l'anglais
ouais je trouve c'est plus facile
est-ce que tu parles quelques mots parce
que tu as commencé en septembre où tu
viens juste de débuter
j'écoutais en asie comme en ont fait un
de compte jusqu'à 10 pour voir où nous
d'où tri farc vit mme sess c'est au cna
au dec
à vous donc effectivement il ya des
côtés latin il ya des côtés aussi un peu
germanique
effectivement c'est un mélange de
plusieurs sonorités zamenhof un prix de
nombreuses langues des sondés son
enfance puisqu'il vivait déjà dans une
région vont parler plusieurs langues
son père était professeur d'allemand
donc il a appris l'allemand assez
rapidement et puis à l'école il a appris
l'anglais et puis il a appris le russe
le le latin et le grec bien évidemment
le français aussi
et chaque fois qu'il a appris qu'il a
abordé une langue nouvelle
il a essayé de repérer quelles étaient
les caractéristiques les plus communes
donc là
la langue s'est construite sur ses choix
progressif de ce qui lui apparaissait
comme comme étant le plus commun toutes
les langues
le plus indispensable c'est pour ça que
j'ai qui ment quand tu comptes
on a des sonorités qui nous reviennent
forcément dans la tête
enfin une petite pause dans cette
émission est allé dans les rues de 50
ans ni vous pour demander ce que les
gens savaient de l'espéranto a écouté
leurs réponses
non c est-à-dire d'espéranto c'est une
danse et non j'ai pas une danse cib
langue universelle ramener quelque chose
mais apparemment il ya quelque chose
j'ai rien eu de plus espéranto espérer
et contournements je connais pas
l'espéranto pas vraiment non ah oui je
crois que c'est un resto aussi donc ça
non pas du tout je connais mais je ne
maîtrise pas donc l'espéranto au
lieu-dit n'est pas un resto c'était
c'est bien la langue universelle monique
et encore du travail à faire moi pour
apprendre à faire connaître permettre
cette lampe vrai qu'on voit d'autres
images avant de conclure cet entretien
notamment une partition parce que
l'espéranto à son hymne
oui là espère c'est un sexy de musique
alors oui le texte et de sabine off et
la musique et de du mesnil et
et donc les espérantistes chante vol
lorsqu'ils sont attachés à ces coutumes
anciennes puisque dès le début du dès le
début du 20e siècle les limes et chanter
au début des congrès des premiers
congrès scientiste et en plus c'est
chanter aussi à 50 on y loue puisqu'on a
un groupe musical c'est la langue qui
est chanté par ce que le l'ensemble
vocal de saint quentin en yvelines
dirigée par valérie josse a
effectivement mis au programme de ces
derniers concerts des pièces en et en
espéranto dont les textes ont été
composées par par des poètes
espérantiste et la musique est aussi une
musique de compositeurs espérantiste
donc si on veut écouter chanter
l'espéranto peut aller du côté de
l'ensemble vocal de saint quentin en
yvelines 6 organiser des prochains
concerts merci beaucoup à vous d'être
venu sur le plateau de télé film nous
parler de l'espéranto
on n'a pas pu parler de votre histoire
personnelle mais c'est intéressant de
dire que vous êtes né de parents
espérantiste et que vos enfants sont
aussi espérantistes qui a des lignes est
comme ça des espérantistes qui vous il
ya des familles entières et là n'est pas
du tout exceptionnel il yad'autres
d'autres espérantistes qui qui ceux qui
ce sont mon fils de mon fils m'a demandé
un jour comment à partir du moment où
commence à apprendre l'espéranto
comment peut-on renoncé à l'utiliser
c'est quelque chose qui paraît
impossible parce qu'effectivement c'est
tellement tellement pratique est
tellement utile et enfin la famille vous
parlez français vous parlez espéranto eh
bien ça dépend des circonstances
c'est lui qui vient de loin donc ça sera
ma famille était une partie de la
famille qui parle en espéranto et puis
il y en a d'autres qui parle de soi le
suédois le le polonais ou bien le
serbo-croate ou d'autres biens merci
merci à vous d'être venu sur plateau
17,8 le journal allez on va quitter le
monde des lettres pour à celui non pas
des chiffres mais du sport on va
direction à voisins le bretonneux pour
parler donc de football et pas de
miracle pour les féminines de voisins
contenu qui recevait bourges ce dimanche
pour le compte de la 5è 5e tour de la
coupe de france sur le papier deux
divisions d'écart en faveur de bérulle
guerre et lévis sinoise ont bien résisté
en s'octroyant même de belles occasions
en première partie à 0 0 à la pause
en seconde partie à les joueuses de
bourges accentuent la pression la
gardienne de voisins-le-bretonneux fait
des miracles mais à quelques minutes du
de sifflet final c'est la sentence au
bourg je marque un but et on s'en est
fini pour la coupe de france 2006 - vont
devoir se replonger dans le championnat
et tenter d'accrocher une nouvelle
montée on va écouter leur coach oui
décision parce que j'étais déjà combat
que vous pouvez dire quelque chose
avant le match je suis encore plus après
donc pour ça que je suis déçu mais fier
de la prestation des joueuses c'est ce
que j'attendais d'elle
je pense qu'elles sont certainement plus
déçu que moi parce qu'ils avaient à
coeur de d'accéder au tour au tour
suivant mais bon voilà une équipe de
bourges qui était réaliste nous on n'a
pas su mettre celle qu'il fallait mettre
et puis toujours en sport à deux mois
des championnats du monde sur piste qui
auront lieu du 18 au 22 février au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l équipe de france vient d'inaugurer un
nouvel outil pour améliorer ses
performances
un banc aérodynamique sic alors ça va
souffler pour les coéquipiers de
françois pervis anthony rech
violaine thorez elodie moines ils
l'attendaient depuis trop longtemps à
deux mois des championnats du monde sur
piste de saint quentin en yvelines les
membres de l'équipe de france peuvent
désormais travailler leur aérodynamisme
en soufflerie
moi ça fait au moins dix ans j'attends
ça donc maintenant d'avoir ça
juste auprès du vélodrome à deux
kilomètres de notre l'entraînement c'est
parfait si la qualité des entraînements
tricolore est reconnu à travers le monde
il manquait aux pistards français une
expertise technique
cette soufflerie faisait d'ailleurs
partie du cahier de commandes des
coureurs de l'équipe de france après les
jeux olympiques de 2012 car le retard
sur les britanniques habitués de cette
technologie commençait à se creuser
je dirais que c'est plus une manière de
prendre de l avance par rapport aux
autres leur faut d'abord récupérer son
retard effectivement et peut-être
prendre de l'avancé parce
qu'effectivement nous n'avions pas ces
tests en soufflerie ce que faisaient
déjà les britanniques pour partie et l'a
vu le niveau d'expertisé
on espère qu'on sera même encore plus
pointue en matière de soufflerie que
dans cette pièce les coureurs vont
pouvoir optimiser leur prise au vent ou
encore les puissances développées tout
sera examiné à la loupe
l'objectif gagner ces précieux millièmes
qui permettront de décrocher de nouveaux
titres aux mondiaux et à rio en 2016
ça va apporter énormément puisque on va
s'améliorer sur notre posture sur le
vélo notre position est également
comment se positionner mais s'il faut
écarter plus les bras ou puisse les
rentrées les coudes ou la tête un peu
plus se baisser
en course le coureur représente 80% de
la prise au vent
l'équipe de france a déjà perdu un titre
pour un millième de seconde c'est dire
si dans l'élite du cyclisme mondial
chaque détail a son importance et puis
une image pour terminer ce journal ou
plutôt cinq pastel des pastels signé du
portraitiste valeur en vaillant acquis
par le château de versailles ces oeuvres
sans doute commandé en 1660 par anne
d'autriche à l'occasion du mariage de
son fils représente louis xiv marie
thérèse d'autriche anne d'autriche
marianne d'autriche et eléonore de
segonzac et permet au site signifie que
2015 sera l'année du tricentenaire de la
mort de louis xiv voilà le journal se
termine sur cette photo de famille
rendez vous demain à 18 heures toujours
en direct vous retrouverez wilfried
richy je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée